i hear you're killing people again
what?
new documentary everyone's talking about it -
talc's full of asbestos, you've been putting
asbestos in our makeup the whole time
do all the chemists and
toxicologists making the products know?
don't know they weren't in the documentary
huh that's weird they seem
like the obvious people to ask
what experts did they use?
lawyers
talking about science? were
they at least unbiased lawyers?
they're representing the people suing over talc
oh come on it's really convincing
they show the girl who exposed
claire's crying and everything
wait wasn't that like five years ago? so
were they already filming then or did they
purposely make her cry so they could
film it? because that's kind of a lot
i don't know but i'm convinced
unless you do a video about it
it's michelle of lab muffin beauty science
chemistry phd cosmetic chemist and person who
like pretty much everyone i think
is concerned about her health
but not so into people trying to exploit
this concern for attention or for profit
hbo have a new 4-part documentary not so
pretty and it's about supposedly dangerous
beauty products this kind of documentary comes
out every six months or so and everyone panics
and throws out their products i've watched it with
some of my cosmetic chemist friends who are all
really knowledgeable you should go follow them all
today i'm going to be breaking down episode one
like and subscribe if you like talking
about the science behind beauty products
episode one is called makeup and it's mostly about
asbestos in talc talc is a powdery ingredient
that's commonly found in makeup and baby powder
and there's some controversy about how talc can
sometimes be contaminated with asbestos asbestos
is a spiky mineral that's linked to some forms of
cancer they discussed what happened with claire's
makeup which was found to contain asbestos in
2017 and johnson and johnson baby powder which
is the subject of a whole bunch of lawsuits from
plaintiffs claiming that it caused their cancer
mostly ovarian cancer but also mesothelioma a
cancer that's closely linked to asbestos exposure
before we go any further i need to remind
everyone documentaries aren't science in
science we try to conduct fair tests then we
look at all the data to work out what it tells us
if the studies disagree you have to work out which
studies are flukes which ones weren't fair which
ones aren't relevant and which ones were just
plain wrong if there isn't a conclusive answer you
have to work out how much certainty there is and
what the sensible thing is to do in the meantime
documentaries don't have to play by these rules
they need to tell a good story and this story
is chosen by the filmmakers who generally
aren't experts in the topic because they're
experts in making films you would hope that
the documentary makers would consult relevant
experts and base their documentary on what the
science says but there's no obligation to do that
you would also hope that they would
try to be transparent that they would
say if the relevant experts that they
approached disagreed with what they said
foreshadowing
but again there's no real rules they can choose
to only show the bits of evidence that fit the
narrative they already had in mind and this
is commonly called cherry picking it's like
only showing footage of snow to make it
seem like global warming isn't happening
and unfortunately science is complex it usually
doesn't make as good a story as a sensational
black and white cherry-picked narrative
that plays on fears and misconceptions
that we the audience already have
and if i watched not so pretty without
already knowing a lot of the background
i probably would have been quite convinced
this is a really slickly made series that
does actually bring up some good points but
then it mixes them in with a lot of really bad
points and they support it with very unobjectively
selected evidence and questionable leaps of logic
so the first episode makeup the main
theme is the idea that products with
talc contain asbestos and therefore they have
a high chance of causing harm to consumers
they're mostly talking about powder makeup like
eye shadow and face powder and talcum powder
the episode focuses on a 26 year old woman corrin
who was diagnosed with mesothelioma a type
of cancer that's usually caused by asbestos
so the documentary makes the case
that asbestos in corrin's makeup
caused the mesothelioma and that her story
is representative of the dangers to consumers
from talc in makeup they also talk about how
kristi found asbestos in claire's makeup in 2017
which was a huge story at the time
and this leads to the conclusion
to me there are a lot of issues
with this whole line of reasoning
the first issue this documentary never mentions
that there's a lot more data on asbestos and
talc products other than this one woman's makeup
collection and what happened with this one brand
the reason that asbestos in claire's makeup was
such a big story was that it was really shocking
it's rare and unexpected and quite glaringly the
documentary doesn't talk about how this claire's
incident actually spurred the FDA to start
investigating asbestos and talc in cosmetics
there is a section of the FDA website
that is entirely dedicated to talc this is
a pretty huge thing for them not to mention
to the point where it feels like maybe they
deliberately left it out because this episode does
talk a lot about how the FDA doesn't do enough but
for this specific issue with talc and asbestos
the FDA have actually done something they've
been updating methods for detecting asbestos and
looking for asbestos in talc containing products
they did two surveys in 2019 and 2021 and
they used the more sensitive techniques that
the geologists in the documentary mentioned
i find it hard to believe that the
filmmakers could have missed this
it comes up immediately if you google talc FDA
in the 2019 FDA survey 52 products from 23
brands were tested asbestos was found in
nine products from three brands three out
of five products from claire's five out of
seven products from city color and one out
of two baby powders from johnson and johnson
in the 2021 survey they tested 50 products from
33 brands and no asbestos was detected in any of
them these numbers are most likely higher
than what's on the market because the FDA
prioritised testing brands and products
that they suspected had asbestos
so in total that's three brands out of 53 that
had talc containing products with asbestos
and nine products out of the
102 tested that had asbestos
on the other hand 10 out of 25 of corrin's
products had asbestos this is close to half
so it doesn't seem to be representative of talc
containing cosmetic products on the market overall
there's also the fact that people who use more
makeup don't seem to be noticeably more prone
to mesothelioma mesothelioma is linked to asbestos
exposure but it's usually prolonged heavy exposure
such as in people who work in industries
where there's a lot of asbestos and even
then most asbestos workers don't get mesothelioma
asbestos is a trace contaminant in cosmetic talc
and as the FDA surveys showed it isn't often
in there when it is it's in really tiny amounts
on the other hand before the mid-1980s
huge amounts of asbestos were used in
construction since it's a good insulator and
it's fireproof it was used in wall insulation
pipe insulation roof shingles textured ceilings
and walls two-thirds of houses built between
the 1930s and 1980s in australia contain
asbestos as do more than half of u.s homes
it generally isn't a big problem unless you're
renovating your house or the panels containing
asbestos are falling apart because they're
getting old or because of a natural disaster
when this happens the spiky asbestos particles can
be released into the air and you can breathe it in
which is the main route of exposure that leads
to mesothelioma there's also asbestos in old
brake pads and as they wear down and get
used the asbestos fibres go into the air
so typically the people who get mesothelioma
are blue collar workers who work closely
with lots of asbestos as part of their job
there are also higher rates in people who
live near asbestos mines and factories
and people who live with asbestos workers since
they can bring home asbestos dust on their clothes
on top of that asbestos in the air is higher in
a lot of cities because of brakes four times as
many men are diagnosed with mesothelioma than
women and most of these men are over 65 which
overwhelmingly points towards working with large
amounts of asbestos being the biggest issue
in the us there are about 3000 diagnoses per year
so it's a relatively rare cancer there's no known
increased risk for makeup artists or models or
people who manufacture cosmetics or mothers with
many children which you would expect if using
makeup or baby powder was a big risk factor
and the amounts of asbestos
in makeup and baby powder
are so small to begin with compared to
how much is in a lot of homes for example
this doesn't mean that asbestos in makeup and
baby powder will never cause even a single case
of mesothelioma you can be really unlucky a tiny
asbestos fibre could just happen to land in the
exact wrong place to cause health problems
but more exposure to asbestos means there's
a higher chance of this happening and it seems
like a pretty big distortion of the actual risk
to spend 35 minutes talking about tiny
amounts of asbestos in a small number
of makeup and baby powder products and warning
people to avoid all products with talc without
ever mentioning how you should be careful
about drilling into walls and older houses
or cracked ceiling panels or getting an asbestos
evaluation of your house before you renovate
these things could reduce your exposure to
a lot more asbestos and they're recommended
on official health websites whereas
makeup and baby powder aren't mentioned
and one possibility that stephen
raised in our live viewing is that
maybe it would be worth investigating if
corrin has an asbestos problem in her house
probability-wise it's a much more likely
explanation for why a young woman might develop
mesothelioma than using makeup it would also
explain why her makeup products are so much more
contaminated than the products on the market maybe
they did investigate it but it isn't mentioned
whether or not that is the underlying reason her
experience isn't representative of the overall
safety of talc containing products in the US
anecdotes like these are really persuasive we
can see these people we can relate to them we
can get emotionally invested in their stories
but it's still just one example that may or
may not tell us about the overall picture
and the real things we should be focusing on
the choice of experts that not
so pretty used in this episode
also seems to point to cherry picking in this
episode they only feature one relevant scientist
a geologist who analyses talc samples for
asbestos almost all of the explanations that
we get about the science of asbestos and talc
and their health risks are from two lawyers
both represent plaintiffs in talc cases as
well as a journalist so it's an extremely
one-sided view that's being presented we are
basically just hearing one side of a court case
you would maybe expect some input from relevant
qualified scientists like cosmetic chemists
or toxicologists who work in cosmetic safety
or asbestos so why don't they appear in this?
well it turns out that some cosmetic chemists
were actually approached by the filmmakers
perry and valerie of the beauty brains podcast but
their perspective didn't match what the
documentary makers seemed to already have in mind
and i'm sure they couldn't have been the only
relevant experts that were approached and left out
it's also a bit questionable how this episode is
called makeup it starts and ends talking about
makeup but most of the middle is actually spent
talking about baby powder i think this is because
there is a stronger case against baby powder
there's a lot more talc in baby powder than
in makeup to begin with and most of the lawsuits
on talc are against johnson & johnson so why did
this episode focus so much on makeup rather than
baby powder and try to like mash the two together?
i would guess it's because j & j stopped selling
talc baby powder in the US in 2020 so a baby
powder episode wouldn't be as attention-grabbing
"this thing you probably can't buy anymore could
be dangerous" is just not going to be as viral
as "the stuff you use every day is killing you"
as jen mentioned in our viewing it's also worth
noting that most of the lawsuits were actually
about talcum powder causing ovarian cancer not
mesothelioma again this seems to be a deliberate
choice a paper looking at the data from over
a quarter million people was published in 2020
and it found that there was no significant
increase in the risk of ovarian cancer
for people who use powder in their genital area
importantly the authors weren't involved in any
talcum powder lawsuits which is very
rare for newer publications about talc
so it seems like the documentary
makers might have purposely gone for
a smaller issue that's a bit harder to debunk
because the bigger issue's fallen through
all the episodes of not so pretty also bring up
real complex important issues involving inequality
race access to healthcare workplace protections
and social justice but a lot of the time they
imply that we can solve these issues just by
changing the ingredients in your beauty products
for this episode they say consumers can act by
avoiding all talc products which as we talked
about earlier isn't a recognised risk factor
they don't mention any of the other better
recognised preventative things you could do
that medical organisations actually
recommend they also recommend using
so it's really pushing clean
beauty apps and clean beauty logic
where ingredients can be neatly divided into good
and bad and you can work out how safe a product is
based on just the ingredients list
i've talked about this before it is
a really clever marketing technique but
it's just not the way the world works
how safe an ingredient is depends on how you're
exposed to it this is a very basic principle in
toxicology the most important factor is usually
how much there is a concept that's commonly
referred to as "the dose makes the poison" the
ingredients list usually doesn't have many numbers
clean beauty apps and websites also often
misinterpret studies they'll take studies
on cells and animals where they might have fed
the ingredient to rats or injected it into them
and they just assume that they have the same
health effects in humans and the thing is proper
trained toxicologists have actually analysed
the same studies before and published their
conclusions and cosmetic chemists use ingredients
and products based on their recommendations
so on one side you have scientists with
years and years of specialised knowledge
saying that these ingredients are
safe when used in certain ways
you also have formulators who know where they got
their ingredients from they know the impurities
in them they know how much they put into the
product and they know these safe recommendations
and then on the other side you have
these clean beauty organisations that
don't know how much is in the product or where
the ingredient comes from saying that it is
just blanket unsafe plus these organisations
seem not to know that humans aren't cells in
a petri dish or rats and really just the basics of
toxicology the two sides are just really not equal
and then to recommend clean beauty as the
solution to these complex social problems
it makes me really frustrated because these
issues really need to be solved and the well
researched solutions are complex and
a lot of people are working on them
but not so pretty are really
emphasising these oversimplified
fake solutions that aren't supported by the
evidence so they won't solve these issues
they could just act as a distraction and
make things worse they also make consumers
waste a whole bunch of money by throwing out
perfectly good products and buying even more
and a lot of the ways this episode
brings up these issues in the first place
just don't really make sense for example one of
the lawyers said that j&j's baby powder marketing
which is made up by the documentary
to be kind of sinister and predatory
and that "according to lawsuits"
it has something to do with the
fact that this demographic would be
less likely to get an early diagnosis
and again inequality of access to healthcare
due to race and other socio-economic factors
is a really big problem but demographic based
marketing is standard people from different
cultural backgrounds use different products and
one of the big uses of baby powder is for reducing
chafing between the thighs in hot and
sweaty weather so it seems like there's
a much more straightforward explanation
that doesn't involve a huge evil conspiracy
the documentary also says that j&j
but j&j's talc baby powder is also
still sold in a whole bunch of
very white european countries
like ireland switzerland
germany and norway which goes against this
whole "targeting women of colour" theory
so the good points i think this episode
made i completely agree with this bit
i think a lot of us have seen posts on
social media about products with mold
product textures changing in concerning ways
products with dishonest advertising like filters
and illegal drug claims some of us have
even submitted complaints to regulators
and realised that very few of these get
dealt with in any official sort of way
this isn't just a problem in the US it's a
problem pretty much everywhere and the FDA
does actually do more than a lot of other
countries the EU system tends to get recommended
by a lot of clean beauty advocates but on this
specific issue their regulators haven't actually
publicly investigated asbestos or published
any surveillance testing like the FDA studies
i think it's a pretty crap situation that a
regular consumer had to test the claire's makeup
it just seems like the sort of issue that
regulators should be more proactive in tackling
i also agree that the texas two-step scheme
that j & j are using sounds pretty crappy it's
a legal loophole that allows companies
to massively reduce payouts in lawsuits
and it seems unsurprising that companies
are going to try to reduce their losses
as much as they legally can hopefully
legislation will close this loophole
so my takeaways first off asbestos doesn't seem
to be a common issue in cosmetics according to
better evidence that the documentary seemed to
purposely ignore if you're still uncomfortable
using talc maybe avoid using talcum powder this is
one of the bigger sources of talc and cornstarch
based alternatives work pretty well the amount
of talc in makeup that you breathe in is pretty
small to begin with and based on those fda surveys
asbestos in makeup doesn't seem to be a big issue
more importantly if you're worried about asbestos
be aware of the bigger risks like your home and
any other buildings you regularly go to i've left
some links to medical websites in the description
when watching documentaries be really alert about
the ways that they might be manipulating you
some things are hard to spot
unless you already know the topic
but in a lot of documentaries one obvious
red flag is which experts they use
so ask yourself: what experts are they
using? are they the right experts for
the topic they're discussing? are there
obvious categories of experts missing? if so
look up what these experts are saying
i'll be talking about the other episodes soon
so subscribe and click the
nerdification bell for that
also hit the like and leave a
comment if you enjoyed this breakdown
the full convo from our watch party is
a podcast on the eco well there's also a
great book called getting risk right which
i really recommend if you want to get your
head around how to not get on that panic
wagon when these sorts of issues come up